it's a little unusual today I'm gonna be
very honest with you two strange strange
day today several hours ago before this
taping I I heard a lot of us heard the
terrible news that comedian Garry
Shandling had died and I have to tell
you this is a devastating shock to me
into just about everybody I know I've
had I think about three hours now to
process that Garry is gone and this just
doesn't seem real still and I don't know
when it will in the next few days and
probably weeks you're gonna be hearing a
lot and reading a lot about Garry
Shandling the comedian and you're gonna
hear that he was supremely innovative
and intelligent you're gonna hear that
he is revered by everyone in comedy and
that is all true 100% true he was a
masterful writer a performer who went on
to create incredibly groundbreaking
comedy shows that inspired an entire
generation of comedians myself included
but right now I'm not thinking about
that aspect of Garry Shandling I'm
thinking about Garry Shandling the
person he was obviously hysterically
funny pretty much all the time but he
was also extremely sensitive he was
complicated and he had a ton of empathy
for other people and I want to make that
point that is something in this business
in comedy that is very rare he really
did care about other people during a
particularly difficult time in my life
as fate would have it
Garry just magically appeared this is
true and he helped me a lot and that is
what I've been thinking about these last
couple of hours and it's seven years ago
now when my Tonight Show ended in this
crazy effed up spectacular fashion I
woke up the next morning and I had no
job and I had no idea what I was going
to do and I was just shell-shocked and I
was a complete zombie and my wife
suddenly
this idea she said we should go to
Hawaii for a week and she said you
should get some Sun for like the first
time in 40 years I had never seen the
Sun and not since and I thought maybe
that's a good idea
so wife and my two kids and I we got on
a plane and we flew to Hawaii and we
checked into our hotel room and my wife
took our two kids to the beach and
thought let's leave daddy alone you know
and I just sat alone in this hotel room
for I think half an hour 40 minutes just
silent not knowing what to do and I
could hear the ocean and I'm just
sitting there and suddenly the phone
rang and I heard a voice and it's an
unmistakable voice and said Conan it's
Gary
I'm staying three doors down or on an
island there's no avoiding me and sure
enough he had been and he'd checked in
like the day before me and he knew that
I had just heard from somebody hey Conan
O'Brien just he was like Conan's here he
called me up we spent this is a week I'm
supposed to spend with my wife and kids
I spent the entire week with Gary
Shandling yeah it was and I'll tell you
something I was at a real low point he
counseled me he cheered me up he told me
jokes he talked to me about philosophy
he talked to me about how there are
bigger things in the world and how I was
gonna be fine you talk about Eckhart
Tolle he went about all this amazing
stuff we had an incredible one afternoon
the I think the last afternoon that we
spent together on that island
we took this really long walk we climbed
over lava formations we went through a
cave we went to this far part of the
island and we saw a little stretch of
sand and we lay down on it and the Sun
started to go down and we're both
watching the Sun go down I turn to Gary
and I said Gary this is the most
romantic moment of my life and it's with
you this has never had a moment like
this with my wife and I'm having it now
with you he was an incredibly generous
person the first time I hosted the Emmys
I had an idea he agreed to help us with
it he listened to my jokes he punched
them up for the great Gary Shandling to
do that for me was so special so
generous and that particular
collaboration created a moment for me
that special I'll never forget it and I
thought maybe we could just take a
second
in honor of Gary and just take a look in
an effort to get a really big rating NBC
has asked me to develop a love interest
on the show tonight it gets worse
right here right now yeah this is
clearly an idiotic idea romance works on
a sitcom but on an awards show it's
completely unrealistic that it would be
up here at this big moment and suddenly
for no reason spots someone and start
[Music]
[Music]
down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I love you Gary we miss you we will take
a break and we will move this show
forward we'll take a break we'll be
right back we'll stick around